desde diferentes latitudes condenan el
asesinato del presidente yo en el muelle
el hecho causó sorpresas o sobra y
profundo rechazo a lo largo del mundo y
varios mandatarios no tardaron en
solidarizarse con el pueblo haitiano
lamentamos y condenamos el magnicidio
del presidente haitiano yo en el morís y
la primera dama martín moix este crimen
atenta contra el orden democrático de
haití de la región nuestras condolencias
a sus familiares y al pueblo haitiano
además otros países de la región
latinoamericana respaldaron a la familia
ya la ciudadanía haitiana enviaron
abrazó al pueblo
haití
por el lamentable asesinato del
presidente
de ese país y de su esposa sumado al
repudio otros recordaron la carrera
política de moix y ese ese cruel vil y
cobarde asesinato del presidente de
haití un amigo en nuestro país un
defensor de la libertad por su parte el
secretario de estado de eeuu
anthony blinken habló con el primer
ministro interino de haití y ratificó el
compromiso de su nación para trabajar
por la paz y la seguridad del país la
noticia igualmente fue rechazada por el
bloque europeo
conmocionado por el asesinato del
presidente haitiano job en el móvil
tuvimos un encuentro en un foro
diplomático hace solo tres semanas
este crimen conlleva a un riesgo de
inestabilidad de una espiral de
violencia los autores deben ser
encontrados y llevados ante la justicia
el consejo de seguridad de naciones
unidas anunció que se reunirá el jueves
a puerta cerrada mientras que la
organización para los estados americanos
pidió una investigación internacional